hello everybody welcome to another
bitcoin video in this video i'm not
going to be showing you guys any of my
trading for today mostly because there
really was no trading done today bitcoin
didn't really do that much in the way of
movement um today this is the last few
hours from
basically their 9 a.m to 17 o'clock
um
and this is pretty much all it's done i
did get some trading in early on and
then basically sat through this entire
thing here with pretty much no movement
and then here it moved a little bit but
then again pretty much no movement so
um not really anything to show off for
today overall um
i can actually just bring it up um this
is just like all of my bitcoin trading
history
and over here you can see basically how
much i've how much u.s dollars i've
moved how much i've made 20
and
the percent profit
and we started about
two days ago now today
uh of of uh bitcoin flipping now this is
with an original 250 dollar
uh investment so in two days you know i
made 7.7 which is you know that's nice
that's pretty cool
um but
uh it's been pretty slow the last few
days and actually bitcoin's just kind of
been slowly chipping away at value so
um
so there's that
and in fact let me just show you guys
let's uh bring this over
um
bring up the uh bitcoin prices here
yeah so the top line here is the actual
bitcoin price as you can see i mean from
the peak here
really over the last couple days it's
actually just been kind of mostly today
i mean look today's the 14th and it's
just just been like in decline same
thing with obviously like our sentiment
here
sentiments just like nah
so not too much going on today and also
i mean you can even tell like the
volatility of the sentiment here is
pretty big
and then over here it's just pretty
small and in decline so
um be nice if there was i don't know
some more news bits or something so it
always seems like whenever there's big
news
uh or just news at all it doesn't have
to be positive or negative news we just
need some news uh there's stuff
happening but otherwise yeah it's pretty
boring day today
so uh what i wanted to talk about in
this video
is uh the downsides to bitcoin so you
know we've been talking about a lot of
the good things about bitcoin and the
cool things and all this and kind of
dispelling some things
but there are some downsides to bitcoin
and so let's just talk about some of
those so
first they are indeed pretty volatile
um
you know here we only have a couple of
days but you know you can look at a
really long term chart like let's do
something like this
where the price i mean especially as we
were leading up to the point with like
all that news and everything where it
came from 240 to over a thousand dollars
uh per bitcoin that's a lot of change
and um
you know the currency has to level out
before before it can actually be used
like you can't be moving that much
and really it made that move in in less
than a month
so you can't really have that kind of
stuff happening uh for a currency to be
you know usable but everybody references
that but if you actually look at like
what happened before all of that
um you know the the currency was
relatively i mean it was like in in you
know constant increase you know but it
was kind of stable and like i showed you
guys with like the two previous bubbles
you know they would have it and then it
would you know flatline for a long time
before getting to another one so then
this is probably going to do the same
where it you know peaks here and it
slips down and then flat lines that i
don't know i'm not making predictions
but you know something like 400 and in
flat lines there for a while until it's
next little bubble
um
anyway uh so that's that now anyway but
the the issue is though it is indeed
volatile so this gives it kind of an
untrustworthy appearance so every time
it's in the news it's because of its
volatility so every time people hear
about it they're like oh bitcoin's too
volatile
so so it just kind of doesn't really
work out now
um
you know people kind of associate the
high risk with it so with this not many
people even have adopted bitcoin but the
sad part is as more people do adopt
bitcoin like when it gets popular and
people are hearing about in the news and
get curious the price skyrockets because
people are buying into bitcoin
and then when the price skyrockets
people are like hey look at the
volatility you know
and so so there's always that so the
next thing is bitcoin at least in the
media is kind of painted negatively like
that and then also the people that use
bitcoin in the media are just nerds and
criminals so
um one article yeah here we go i saw
this one bitcoin is a segue of currency
so basically you know anybody that you
know the segway was really like touted
like it was like the internet of scooter
or internet of like i don't know foot
travel or something i can't remember
um it was a big deal like i remember
like
um the unveiling of the segway and i was
like
what
and yeah you know people do look kind of
silly on the segway and so that was the
whole point was you know anybody that
uses bitcoin looks you know absurd
um and so anyway
don't really like the article but it is
you know it just gets a whole lot of you
know bad rap basically
um and then also with criminals the silk
road was a pretty big story whenever
that came out um
the site got basically shut down
um the owner i mean first of all i just
want to say what is he doing with his
hand this just this picture bothers me
so much because his hand is like
contorted like
why are you doing this in the picture
anyway i don't like that
um so anyway this guy you know ran silk
road and like if in the article you hear
and you read about this guy like
basically at you know getting this guy
to kill this other guy that was like
threatening him like what was it he gets
red and white
uh this guy named red and white to kill
what was it friendly chemist or
something like that
yeah friendly chemist because friendly
chemist was blackmailing
uh what is this guy called some sort of
pirate i forget what he calls himself uh
yes dread pirate roberts
is what he calls himself so this dread
pirate roberts or dpr calls out a hit on
this guy
and you know apparently he really was
killed but there's no record of this guy
getting killed so uh whatever
um anyway so that that story came out
and it was all bad i'll put these links
in the description this is also like his
uh you know the whole complaint thing on
this guy like the official uh
stuff here
so
um so there's that like it just kind of
gets a bad rap purely because of like a
lot of the people that use it are
criminals um
and also there's obviously a lot of
speculation
you know going
around it
next uh in the last video i showed you
guys how merchants would actually like
bitcoin because it can't be charged back
and volatility really isn't an issue for
the merchant fees are cheaper that said
that is all fine and dandy but where the
merchant's risk declines here
the buyers risk goes up so businesses
like paypal are set up this way like to
make it you know a lot of buyer
protection because that buyer protection
uh encourages more transactions more
business to take place
so bitcoin isn't worried about the risk
of the transaction because the seller
takes on that risk not paypal and not
the buyer so this obviously makes more
business happen and more money made for
paypal so but i can also personally
attest that i've made some purchases
online
knowing that like well i don't really
trust this website but
if uh if
if it's a scam it's super easy to get my
money back over paypal so i i i find
myself making more purchases via paypal
um to websites that i normally wouldn't
like i wouldn't buy some stuff like via
bitcoin to be like oh i might not get my
bitcoin back
so this makes um
bitcoin kind of
even though it's a bonus for the
merchants and even though like
everyone's like oh nobody will ever
accept that because of the volatility
well that's not the problem the problem
is the buyers the buyers aren't
protected
and so that kind of discourages
uh buyers but at the same time as long
as you have a reputation and a reputable
website you know you can do both you can
accept paypal and bitcoin you know you
can do stuff like that too
um
so that kind of pours into the next one
the biggest downside to bitcoin is just
purely it's lack of forgiveness right so
it can't be reversed so this is part of
just it not being regulatable so it
can't be reversed but while that's a
bonus in some respects it's a negative
in other respects there's no undo button
um and there are ways to kind of
mitigate this kind of risk you know of
screwing up or losing your wallets or
whatever but it requires a lot of
responsibility
and also with this bitcoin makes itself
a target for theft as well so this means
both you
and
any exchange or other online wallet that
you use is a target
for theft
and let me find
what i'm looking for i think it was
maybe this one yes the bitcoin or the
great bitcoin bank robbery
this was one of those uh things let me
let's click on this one hopefully i can
get the name i want to get the name of
the uh bank i can't remember what the
name was but
like everybody's just like linking to
each other like oh we got the
information here
oh okay trade fortress that was the
right one so uh it was a bitcoin bank
called trade fortress and so
um
the the story is that one million
dollars worth of bitcoin was stolen uh
from the bank but
no one can really prove whether or not
it was this kid that stole it or if it
really was theft and if it really was
theft there's no way to find the thieves
and actually punish the thieves
great
hopefully that didn't just kill
everything
anyway
um so you can't really find out who's
doing these these thefts so so you and
the exchanges become a target for this
stuff because you can take the money and
run away and there's really no way to
come after these people
now since we landed on this page i was
just going to make this kind of the last
thing but
big updates like this like china bars it
bought its banks from
um doing bitcoin transactions so no
longer can can the china banks actually
uh
work with uh bitcoin the you know
chinese people can but the banks cannot
um so that was kind of big news because
china's
i think at the time china was the number
one market actually for bitcoin and that
was where the most bitcoin growth was
actually occurring
um so that was kind of a hit to bitcoin
itself when they did that
and then also uh just recently the new
york was
basically they released this statement
saying you know hey we're looking into
the possibility of regulating bitcoin
but they didn't really say too much else
about that it was mostly just like an it
was like it was a notice of inquiry
um so not really much there but still
the possibility for them to continue
trying to put sanctions on bitcoin is
always a possibility
uh the next thing uh was also bitcoin
mining is kind of a risk because it's
profitable to do bitcoin mining but
sometimes most of the time it's
inefficient actually
in the old days you know people would
infect your computer to use its
performance for maybe ddos attacks ad
clicking schemes or something like that
or that might be after maybe your
personal information
these days and it's already happening
people are using your computer with uh
bitcoin mining trojans
and they mine bitcoin on your computer
um so here's an example of one this
company that is a gaming company fined a
million dollars because they were
secretly using uh players computers to
mine bitcoin now i don't think it was
this one but i remember reading another
article where it was just in the in the
terms of service right that you accept
that they said hey we're going to use
your computer to mine bitcoin and that's
totally
legal
or at least i i want to say it was ruled
to be totally legal um
so that could totally change so it just
depends but so don't think that you know
just because you have some sort of
software that you can do this
uh but it is kind of legal and also um
yeah in the form of micro transactions
and also like freeware right
this this is a form of freeware like hey
you want to use my product uh you don't
have to pay for it but you have to mine
it so so even though like this was
secretly using it um and that's bad but
that also does kind of give you the idea
that it does open the door to
mic a form of micro transactions where
you just use our product and while
you're using it you have to see
not secretly you have to mine bitcoin
like while you're using our products
stuff like that
um
so there is you know even though that's
kind of this is kind of sad to see but
at the same time this sort of thing
probably
can become the norm and become part of
freeware um even though that's not
necessarily free but it's a sort of
freeware where you don't have to pay for
it actually
so anyways those are just some of the
downsides to bitcoin i think the the two
biggest downsides that i are going to
hinder bitcoin overall
and really just the one is
the lack of
you know reversibility in a transaction
so this means that buyers aren't
protected and then also it's just kind
of opens the door for a lot of theft to
uh occur you know uh especially because
you can
it's not totally anonymous but
there's things that you can do to make
bitcoin completely anonymous
uh or at least very difficult for
someone to track much more difficult
than stealing money from a bank or a
another person or whatever
um so i think in the long term that's
going to be something that people have
to kind of hash out whether or not
they're willing to take the unregulated
nature of bitcoin and make that trade uh
you know and decide that they want
unregulated for increased uh risks
elsewhere
um
and i think that's something that you
have to think about yourself as well
because it is a serious decision to make
but
anyway those are just some of the the
downsides to bitcoin i'm sure there are
a ton another small ish downside is is
how it's produced uh it's not very
environmentally friendly way to
generate a currency and then also just
like the banks have to run a bunch of
computers to process transactions even
once all the bitcoins are done being
created
i want to say it's 2140
it's either that or 2040 but i'm pretty
sure it's 21.40 um that all of the
bitcoins will be completed and then it's
like well what do people do after that
well after that you you just get paid
the transaction fees
and
uh that'll be what mining bitcoin is all
for you know just to keep the network
going and the transaction fees going
and the other curiosity is how big the
blockchain will be by that time
um because that will only continue
getting bigger um so there's a few
things that'll have to come into
consideration in the future too like
what happens is that you know anybody
that you know downloads some of this
bitcoin stuff now like bitcoin i think
qt like the full bitcoin thing
uh you have to download i forget what
the size of it is right now like i swear
it was like two or three gigabytes or
something worth of you know blockchain
information and as
as the
as more and more people start getting on
board and there are more and more
transactions taking place
uh you're gonna find that blockchain is
gonna grow really fast
and get pretty big so that's kind of an
issue to consider
um but i've read a few
things that have kind of gone about that
maybe we'll talk about that more in the
future
um
but that but i think yeah the biggest
the biggest issue is just going to be
this this lack of forgiveness and
non-reversibility
is going to be the issue so
anyway that's going to conclude it uh
i'm sure i missed some things that are
bad if you want to comment below and add
some more things that are you know bad
with bitcoin
do feel free
anyway as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and the donations
and until next time